- But you both have cool
meanings to your names.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- So tell us yours.
- So my last name is Iseman,
which actually has been shortened
for the German Eisenman,
which means iron man.
- [Kelly] Oh my.
- Oh Avengers.
- I know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Nick Fury, right over
here it's really cool.
Although my dad did tell me,
actually that probably means
we were junk collectors.
(laughing)
- That is cool.
- But, I thought the name
Matt Iseman was kinda boring.
So the very first time
I do stand up comedy,
the very first time I went on stage,
I did not go on as Matt Iseman.
I went on as Rock Iseman.
- You were the rock before..
- I was the rock before Dwayne Johnson,
- Dwayne Johnson, he jacked your stock.
He stole it.
- He did.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was lifting well.
- You can sue him for that, you know.
- You think?
- Yeah.
- [Matt] I'm gonna let
The Rock have that one.
- I think you should both battle it out
and see which one wins.
(laughs)
- It will all be (mumbles) Matt
Iseman then, pretty clearly.
- I'm just saying both big men.
So it might be fun to watch.
So what about your name?
What does your name mean?
- Yeah, so my great, great grandfather
was a seven foot mediator in the village.
- Seven feet tall?
- in Nigeria.
Yes, seven feet tall.
That's how I got my six, six height.
- Wow.
- It got passed down to me,
but whenever people would
have issues in their area,
they would call on him to come mediate it.
- So they go (speaking
in foreign language)
meaning big man come and save me.
So that's where the last name came from.
Big man come save me.
So I'm supposed to be a mediator.
So I'll mediate between you and The Rock
for the name Rock.
- I will say, out of meanings.
He may be wins cause you collect iron.
So (laughs).
- I know, I'm a junk collector.